okay i will say with cheating okay if a
guy cheats on me
now
i'm gonna leave right and the reason
being is because
i feel like
like we're not even married yet like
okay if you're doing it now like
the future can't be bright right but i
think if you have a child it's not about
you anymore
so if i had a kid with someone i would
try to work it out yeah because i think
like like your feelings are kind of
irrelevant when you have a kid and i
would never want to put a kid at a st
like at every like that's how do you put
it sorry um at a disadvantage for their
life and like a kid is at every
statistical disadvantage if they don't
have both parents in the home like
they're more like 80 of people in prison
we're born from a single parent home
um
about i mean i'm a nanny i work as a
nanny for 10 years and i've seen
a lot of kind of different families
single mothers both parents
and i came from a c i mean my mom is
single
and she raised me i i had no father
present in my life and
that was good i think because he cheated
on my he my father cheated on my mom so
and she needed she never wanted to work
out and i think that's best because if
you don't trust the person then in the
back of your head you're gonna always
have trust issues and then those trust
issues that will
um you know lead in your head
like to travel like
in the house and
for this child like to see the parents
like fighting all the time for little
things because they don't trust each
other well but that's why that's how you
like go to therapy and like find other
ways to work it out and afford
i mean therapy yeah i just everyone can
have that luxury you know to have
therapy or to have people around them
and to support them because we are you
know we're not all coming from the same
place right yeah but like even
like before the invention of like birth
control like honestly people stayed
together through thick and thin
people didn't just leave like like
there's so many times where the grandpa
had like a family on the other side of
town nobody knew about
yeah but that was because instagram
right because now these days
you know they always see and a better
option they go so you know don't work on
they don't and it's not i just i just
think like at the end of the day it's
not about you when you have children
like like like why would you want to put
your kid at that disadvantage like i i
know getting cheated on is terrible like
that's a whole like that is the worst
feeling in the world like you feel like
absolute [ __ ] but like at the end of the
day if i had kids like it's not about me
it's not about my feelings
it's about the kids go ahead so if your
your partner cheated on you when you had
kids you would stay with them
but how many times let's say cheated on
you 10 times and you caught him i did it
has to be like a limit there is there's
i think it's like if um
if he gave me something i think i would
leave yeah like like an std or something
or like
if um it became like public you know i
mean like he was doing it so much like
everyone knows you know
um
i don't know i'd have to think more
about it there is a line but i'm saying
if it's like a one-time thing
like i don't know men and women are
different and you you would stay with
him
if i had kids i would try to work it out
i would give him probably a chance yeah
i think everyone does mistakes and
nobody's perfect
but more than once no i would cheat
around him on purpose then my idea
actually wait wait
wait wait
direction you have to play the same
price
pay for apple i give you an apple okay
that's it with me
right here no no no well you realize
that that lowers your value
like you're you're kind of playing
yourself because like you're just saying
oh i'm for the strength
forgiving so many times this guy who
cheated on you all the time so just
because you have a kid i mean i don't
want my kids to be raised by a guy that
is a cheater because even just being but
then he'll be raised by two cheaters
i would never accept a cheater to come
back to my life okay
never you know never you've never done
that no i've never been cheated
um so yeah
and let's pray for him if he cheated on
me and i know i'll go back to my ex and
then probably i will cheat around him
but i have no kids i can do it
no i'm joking okay
anyway don't keep talking keep talking
okay okay so
you would if you were me
if you were me if i would work on the
relationship we have a kid and he
cheated on me okay i would forgive him
once but twice huh you're dumb
i just
i just think okay
hello he cheated on you again oh yeah
come on
talking
to follow those steps well i know but
you're giving him more of an example to
follow up
if i was you okay okay the first time
you cheated on me okay i forgive you god
forgive you too okay
we have a kid okay family let's let's
have a happy family second time oh
i will show you how to cheat then
i will invite him i actually imagined
these in my head you know
okay
the best looking guy i find you know and
then i [ __ ] him instead of my husband
whatever it is wait but i'd say you
would you wouldn't
you would okay okay let me let me just
let me just let me just get this
straight let me know he feels what i
felt not just once but twice uh
darling okay let me let me let me just i
don't know one i feel like the guy would
probably leave
that's good okay
second you realize like
okay
this is what we mean by girls cheat
worse
[Music]
bringing us back to the beginning
exactly
[Music]
and that's it you cannot handle [ __ ]
don't start the game that's it okay okay
but how does that help you
a lot
no how does that that guy the indigo is
going to be more little than his penis
no it won't oh god
that's all he's gross
you have to be careful don't cheat on my
girl you know because this girl
did this to me you know and then the
word is going to spread it's gonna be
worldwide and then she's gonna be
working
in the whole world okay okay
okay okay but
okay but you really he's just going to
look at you like you're a hoe oh
okay a guy cheats he's a hero
hold your mouth up
okay so i got he cheats he's a hero he's
not a hoe and if we forgive no no he
comes home ah baby
okay because because then she cheats
she's at home
yes
yes
yes girl yes yes and i and i understand
that men and women are different like
what do they say
yeah there's a love like it's the same
thing if he cheats on me i do that i'm
not just i'm not a cheater yeah i will
do that in the first place right i'm
saying on your behalf okay if you were
me
that's what you would do if i had a
cheater okay i would never accept him
back even if i had 10 children i would
make him pay for the 10 children yeah
you would help me you know like come you
know with the money being present at
their life at their events and their
parties all that at school you know all
that
but living with me
that's like
no that's calling myself every day dumb
are you dumb
no
it's a lot for me so no but i was saying
on your behalf okay if he cheats on me
once i forgive
twice twice then okay
okay let me just recap here okay okay
okay guys okay okay let me recap okay
one
so he cheats on you once you say we'll
work it out for the kids
okay
then he cheats on you a second time your
solution is to get a really good looking
guy of course to screw you in front of
him yeah i saw him you didn't get a
refund what's what's up with that
okay yeah um i'm gonna
leave him and then and then you leave
him off and he'll tell all his friends
do you tell i don't care you know in the
end of the day i know who i am and he's
been the cheater like since day one he
like he started the cheating game you
know i just finished
you just you cannot handle oh for you
you didn't say
you're left with 10 kids an extra body
and no one to look after you but that's
the thing i'm saying
on this situation on her behalf not me
yeah because she would she would leave
immediately
she's [ __ ]
[Music]
she's just she's just giving me some
advice you know
she's just
you know okay um yeah okay i'll i'll
keep i'll keep i'll keep that yeah i'll
keep that in mind yeah
um we've got some super chat yeah yeah i
got i saw um
i'm okay so sentience okay thank you for
the
i clap for these fifty dollar
oh
super
god i keep dropping my phone today i'm